Mirze Edis hat schon vor langer Zeit
sein Büro auf die Straße verlegt.
Der Bundestagskandidat der Linken weiß:
Anders wird er hier kaum Stimmen gewinnen.
Warum gehen die Menschen
eigentlich nicht mehr wählen?
Haben die ihr Vertrauen an [in]
die Politik verloren?
Ich wüsste auch gar nicht,
wen ich wählen sollte,
weil die tun sich alle nix.
Duisburg-Hochfeld im Westen Deutschlands
ist der Wahlkreis
mit den meisten Nichtwählern.
Nur noch jeder Fünfte gab hier zuletzt
bei der Kommunalwahl seine Stimme ab.
Vor über 30 Jahren ging es
den Menschen in der Stahlregion noch gut.
Doch von den rund 20.000 Einwohnern
verloren viele ihre Arbeit.
Heute leben zwei Drittel von staatlicher Hilfe.
Mirze Edis hat die Geschichte
des Niedergangs hautnah miterlebt.
Er ist in Hochfeld aufgewachsen.
Wir hatten hier Jugendzentren,
die zugemacht haben,
Stadtbad hat zugemacht,
die Freizeitparks sind nicht mehr so attraktiv,
wie sie mal früher waren.
Das heißt, man hat nicht mehr
in diesen Bereichen investiert,
und letztendlich ist es halt die Politik,
die falsche Politik, die jetzt dazu geführt hat,
dass die Menschen das Vertrauen an [in]
die Politik so gesehen verloren haben
und deshalb auch
nicht mehr zur Wahl gehen.
400 Haushalte, ungefähr 2000 Menschen
kommen hier jede Woche zur „Tafel“ –
einem Verein,
der gespendete Lebensmittel verteilt.
Arbeitslose, Einwanderer, Armutsrentner
bekommen hier vieles,
was sie sich so nie leisten könnten.
Sechs Kinder, ohne Schwein.
Die Mitarbeiter verstehen gut,
warum hier kaum einer wählen geht.
Arme Leute haben andere Sorgen,
als zu wählen.
Und ich glaube,
dass sich die Politik und die Menschen
immer weiter voneinander entfernen.
Jemand, der sich heute darum
Sorge machen muss,
wie er denn seinen
Kühlschrank gefüllt bekommt,
den interessiert nicht mehr,
ob die SPD oder die CDU
oder wer auch immer regiert.
Wen man auch hier anspricht:
Die Enttäuschung über die Parteien ist groß.
Arme wie sie seien auch nur
selten Thema der großen Politik.
Keiner fragt die normalen Leute.
Die entscheiden selber, was die wollen.
Und da bin ich enttäuscht.
Ich hab immer gewählt
und gemacht und getan
und hinterher hat man
nur noch bezahlen dürfen.
Nee, also, ich geh nicht mehr wählen.
Hinzu kommt: In Duisburg Hochfeld
leben fast 70 Prozent Einwanderer.
Selbst wer von ihnen
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft hat,
geht selten zur Wahl.
Es ist für mich auch sehr, sehr schwierig,
diese Menschen für Politik zu gewinnen
und auch dazu zu bewegen,
dass sie halt auch zur Urne gehen
und dann halt ihre Stimme abgeben,
weil sie überhaupt gar kein Vertrauen
an [in] das politische System haben.
Mirze Edis will nicht, dass nur
die Gebildeten und Reichen wählen gehen.
Deshalb wird er in seinem Viertel
noch viel unterwegs sein müssen,
um die Menschen hier wieder
für die Demokratie zu gewinnen.